music is all i think about from the
moment i wake up in the morning
to the moment i fall asleep at night
it's very interesting because it it
makes it seem like it could be a good or
a bad thing
to sort of follow your passions and say
this is what i'm going to do like i'm
going to do this or die trying to kind
of quote 50.
so i'm just curious what was maybe that
moment for you
when you came to that crossroads and how
did you
sort of like beg up the courage to keep
going maybe against some
pretty big adversity i'll tell you what
i i was lucky enough
young enough to to to be fearless and i
had a look i got a grandmother who had
my grandmother used to pick cotton my
grandfather just picked up like hey
whatever you doing is way better than
this and we want to make sure
that you have every opportunity so
sometimes you take that with you you say
hey i want to make sure
i do them proud and so whether i land
over here or over there wherever
i know that i've done what
they wanted me to do they wanted me to
pursue whatever dream i was
like i wanted when i was a kid you know
i'd be doing stand-up comedy in the
fifth grade for the
for the uh for the high school this
thing like that so they knew that i had
something that i wanted to do and my
whole community
was like man we gonna we'd be we we're
gonna be here to help you and if you
fall
before your head we'll be we'll be here
so you know so
so i never think that it's a wrong thing
to ever
uh give up on your passion i think
that's the wrong thing don't give up on
your passion no matter what
uh no matter what it is no matter how
old you are you gotta go get it
no i agree with that one and i think
there's just countless
countless examples like ava didn't pick
up a camera until she was
alan rickman got cast in his first movie
in his 40s and so yeah you're right
rick jones didn't have his first hit so
he was in his late 30s
exactly denzel didn't have his big
breaks he was in his 40s
wow yeah yeah it's just true this is
true
um bringing it back to um sort of one of
the themes that's in the film which is
this idea of getting in the zone
obviously when joe gets in the zone that
is that moment of sheer bliss where you
are doing your passion and you're doing
it the highest ability
and living in that joy and i think if i
were to make a guess i would say
it was probably every moment that you're
on the set of rey
and everything that followed up to that
is like an in the zone moment
but do you have any others where you
were just like you knew you were in it
and you're feeling your juices
i mean it's i mean yeah i mean ray was
just
amazing for what it was and what it was
at the time you know it was a movie that
that wasn't really done at a movie house
it was sort of independent but
ray definitely stopped by on that like
when i say his spirit stopped by on it
and that's what you get like or or being
in the zone there's nothing like being
in a stand-up comedy zone like i've been
in some zones
now have i captured it yet on film
that is the ever um
fleeting thing for all comedians can we
capture that moment
where we're killing and everything is
going our way
because a lot of times when we put the
camera on and then we're going to shoot
the special it becomes sterilized
and so it's like you cook somebody in
some of the nutrients out so
uh looking forward to getting back out
doing uh
my standup and getting into the zone and
let
some of these letting some of these
folks know
it's so funny that you say that too
because i think
you wear so many hats musician comedian
um actor producer and all these other
different things um i think folks forget
that like stand up was like that first
thing that sort of brought you onto the
screen
especially those young folks yeah so i
gotta remind them like you know you know
i know they think
i know they thinking someone out here
but boy hold on you wait you hold on a
second
hold on a second you just hold
on well it's funny though because it
talks about the audience and there's
going to be so many of them that you
know maybe
especially with these young kids this
may be the first thing they've ever seen
you do so i'm just curious
what takeaways do you really want to
send the audience home with because
there's so many messages
messages you can pull from this that's
the greatest thing of what pete and kemp
did
but i'm just curious what you're hoping
they take from it you know what
don't be don't unders underestimate some
of these kids
that's what i had to learn like you know
sometimes we were like oh the children
drink milk in a minute but what i
learned was any kid that's 5 wants to be
10 any kids 10 wants to be
in high school any person in high school
wants to be
you know beyond college so our kids now
are a little more
savvy that's why i think it's great what
pete and kemp did
is that they pull it pulls you along
along a little bit it gives you an
opportunity to
see things that my kids have been asking
me about man since they were five or six
where do we come from what do we do i
never get sitting in the uh it's going
to freak me out
too my daughter was like god is here she
was
she was in a little uh a little uh
you know car seat i was like where where
is he
and you know she was talking about god
or whatever that it was and said the
devil's here too i was
old i almost wrecked i'm like what are
you doing so she had
she has these and all the kids they have
these questions already about what it is
and so i think this is wonderful
they're able to see something
entertaining and
and sort of allows your mind to expand a
little bit and think think and
and have a good time as well i love it
too and again with someone like you
that's had like a career in so many
different lanes
you have an audience that comes from you
from totally different places but i
think this is definitely a film
that no matter where they found you
whether it was in living color or
you know collateral or the jamie fox
show they're gonna find a place here
so on that though going back to the
jamie foxx show
if he you know your character in that
one was going to make a jingle
to you know get people snapping their
fingers about soul
you know you got any ideas on where he
would go
don't be left out in the cold
on christmas make sure that you
watch soul so don't be
left out left out in the cold
so oh my gosh
and that comes from you know what that
you know what that comes from i've been
listening to frank sinatra
um like yesterday we was listening to
frank like on our show
we like listen we do like a playlist and
so somebody was like nat king cole frank
so he was listening to naked cold and
frank sinatra so that's what
that's where that came from all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch well first i
have to say what's really interesting
about it i mean pixar does what pixar
does they always move us they always
make us cry but
this film in particular really sort of
poses this question of
whether or not your passion can always
be a good or a bad thing like when
you're
faced with a choice of paying bills or
going on that next audition or
continuing to follow your dreams so
i'm just curious as someone who has been
i'm sure in that position once or twice
when was the moment that you knew okay
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna be a writer
i'm gonna do comedy this is it
uh you know make it there or die trying
kind of thing
yeah i think for me you know when i
moved to chicago in
1992 and and found the world of improv
comedy and
met all of my or almost all of my
dearest friends for my adult life
um that was like oh i found my spark
this is what i want to do and i think i
would have kept doing it
you know i ended up being able to do it
here on a on a
big level but i think i would have kept
doing it if i was still living in
chicago and
running a little theater out of my
basement i would still be doing it and i
would still be
content because it was about being with
those people and
creating something out of nothing with
with those
people um and being part of that
community is
what was sort of most important to me
about it so i definitely think that was
my
spark that i found but uh and i do think
that yeah the movie takes it a level
deeper and that they talk about like
okay if you have a passion but also
don't let that passion consume you and
trying to find
balance in life um which there's no
there's no greater cure for that than
having children because children will
they will pump the breaks for you
wow i love that and also it's good that
you brought up the
improv point because i wanted to bring
up one of your improv sisters he's also
a mom
and i'm sure she chose to do inside out
because it's like okay i gotta make
something for my kids and maybe that was
part of this one too but
are you gonna have a little rivalry
because you know could be
oscar nominated pixar films you could
top her you know
are y'all gonna like have a little war
for which one of you has the best pixar
movie
um no there's never war there is only
love
um but i am like i um so i was in
disneyland
i was gonna say not that long ago but
obviously that was pretty long ago
and i was taking pictures of uh joy
around the park and i was like you're in
the parks you're in the parks because
i'm a big
parks nerd um so no there's there's only
love
there's only sisterhood
friendly rivalry we'll just put it that
way friendly rivalry right for the two
pixar
prince our pixar princesses sisterhood
pushing rivalry
that's what we do at rotten tomatoes
right
okay back to back to the film though um
it talks about you know
getting in the zone right where you feel
like you're clicking and everything is
just
hitting perfect and you feel in zen i'm
just curious like what's your zen moment
was it
playing sarah palin because it was a big
zen moment for me let me tell you
that's so funny you know i do i think
i've said that that looking back on i
call that
that little window of time my a prayer
for owen minnie
moment you have you ever read that book
where it's like this week thing that
happened that he
somehow his whole life had prepared him
for this weird moment that he didn't
expect
um and again going back to the
sisterhood
that i rode that you know eight week
cycle with amy poehler
um it did feel at that time of a little
bit of like
oh were we perhaps was our whole life
leading to this perhaps
and now of course here we are 12 years
later and we've had to
we'd have a lot of life after that
moment as well but
some great life i mean honestly i would
just have you all host the golden globes
every year if i had the choice which i
totally don't but you know if they want
to ask my opinion
i think we're back i think i know i know
but i'm saying in general i would just
have y'all always do it like there
should never be an off amy tina years my
point
ever um and then also there's such a big
part of this movie that's music
um so i would ask you and i know this is
hard for people that love
music but is there one particular song
that moves your soul
that in like the darkest moment of like
i don't know but you have to put that on
and it makes you happy
oh my gosh you know there are many have
you seen that recording that's been
being floated around from the movie
sister act
but it's the little singing oh happy day
and it's the most incredible vocal
and it's the most uplifting it's the
best it's the best song
yes it is um yeah it's whoopi goldberg
is playing stacey abrams and she's
conducting the choir of mail-in ballots
and then the boy is like you know uh you
know democratic voters in pennsylvania
it is
literally like perfect synergy and i
will just
do a quick point of this to say that
rotten tomatoes we have a podcast called
rotten tomatoes is wrong where we go
back and look at a movie
that for some reason maybe had a poor
score but that has become beloved and we
did sister act
two back in the habit because it is a
travesty that that
is only 17 of the tomato meter but is
literally the soundtrack of my
adolescence and one of my all-time
favorite movies so
trust me i was all about that video i
was like look
you should watch our we talk about how
great it is is there any
uh obviously your park's head obviously
that makes you a disney head by by
default
is there any other dream disney project
that you want to do you want to do a
visual album like beyonce i'm sure they
would let you do it
disney visual album i would like to
live in the haunted mansion is that
possible
i would too we could make it
like a tilda swinton kind of art piece
where i live and
i'm just in the haunted mansion for like
a couple weeks disney
green light this please a a dark haunted
mansion
with tina fey tilda swinton i'm gonna
add in some donald glover in there just
because i like seeing you all together
anyway mentioned by donald we got it
this week what is it 151 000 souls going
to the great beyond every day
the count's off
hello miss angela bassett hi jacqueline
i just like hearing you say my name
[Laughter]
well ma'am first let me go ahead and say
congratulations on the film
it is incredible it is beautiful this
movie is so interesting to talk with
artists about because it's a movie that
really sort of puts
on sort of like i would say like a case
against whether or not your passions are
always good or bad
because although we love them and we
live for them there comes a moment i
think with
every artist where it's like is this
gonna be what i'm able to do to pay my
bills even though i love it
and i think everybody comes to that
crossroads at a certain point i'm just
curious if in your history before you
became
the angela bassett if you ever had that
gut check moment and
how you decided that this was what you
wanted to do
i don't i i never actually had it that
it didn't
resound in my ear that loudly
but because you know i mean for myself
from inside because i had it from
outside my mother on one hand you know
those mentors those important people in
your life you know your my mother
my aunt these two very strong pillars
and women in my life
my mother was like go for it oh you were
wonderful and it was dramatic when you
did this
and that and my aunt is like don't waste
a yell education on
theater you know which was a statement
that i remember to this day
but i you also get those other lessons
you don't want to live to regret
you know so here i am you know you
you you you weigh it you weigh it okay
i can always go back to school if this
if my dream doesn't you know fulfill
itself then
then i can live someone else's dream of
me
you know and that just seemed like a
roundabout
way to live life so i thought you know
go for it be smart about it
you know become you know do all the
studying that you can to
to support and undergird this frivolous
affair you're about to journey you're
about to go on
but you want to rise to the top you know
and and be among that you know that's
that small number that number well thank
you ms sanchez
thanks for this advice i'm writing this
down as we speak for like how i'm going
to like conquer the world of writing so
thank you for this very great advice i'm
going to take that to heart
do it smart um i will also say though
too
that you know i'm glad you made this
choice because
we would have been deprived of stella
and
your performances tina and you in black
panther so i'm so glad you went this way
but i'm just curious what was the
performance where you felt
you were in the zone like you are in the
film because i would have to think it
would have to be like
what's love got to do with it i don't
know maybe waiting to exhale what's your
in the zone moment on screen
absolutely tina that for that absolutely
i mean there are some moments where you
are
you know you are physically in pain but
you are just
spiritually filled you know it's it's
channeling through you give yourself
up to the moment is there you know is
there
can you go a further distance to get a
little bit more piece of information or
knowledge that you need
before you sleep then you go so
that and then that allowed you allowed
me
to be to be even freer because i felt
like
you know everything that i could get
every moment a week
i got it then i could allow myself to be
free
you know so absolutely that
i love that and let me just say just
watching that puts me in the zone it
feeds my soul
so i'm so glad it did the same for you
doing it um this movie definitely talks
about how
music and just artistry in general and
finding your spark is the food of life
like that's what you live
for and i'm just curious if there's a
movie or a piece of music or what what
do you do to feed your soul is that is
it what's the record you put on what's
the movie you put on for that
oh you know i'll put on music i'll put
on some jazz it doesn't matter
as long as it's a classic you know um
miles davis the nearness of you
guess who i saw today you know it
you know all of these artists are
they're looking at their life
and then they're channeling those hurts
those joys that
love that lost through this music and it
you know and it has an ability to draw
us
in and touch us and speak to us and get
us there emotionally when we need to be
there are times where i've been waiting
to go on stage and i just
listen to music and turn off everything
else
and the music is like a ride and it
takes you
you know it gets you right you know on
the path to where you need to go before
you step
on that stage um so i'll do that or it
may be
it may be some some anthony hamilton or
some rocky on or something you know
just feel in the groove in the zone
in the groove is this heavens no it's
the great before
this is where new souls get their
personalities quirks and interest before
they go to
earth well first of all congratulations
the movie it's just
it's so touching and beautiful and
musical and just like
this i think celebration of black people
and art so thank you all so much for
making it i cried
you did yes it was so touching because
especially as someone that like
lives in entertainment and i'm sure you
can appreciate this with like you know
your long history of
acting and theater and everything else
it's like it really does put you in that
position of what you love
is what you live for but it can be a
good or a bad thing sometimes like you
know there's always that moment i think
with artists where it's like are you
gonna make it are you gonna keep going
on the next audition are you gonna keep
trying to pursue this path
when a lot of people unfortunately your
character telling them like hey you
gotta you gotta pay the bills so
just wondering what would that moment
for you if there ever was a moment where
you kind of had to say
i gotta keep going because i know i'm
gonna be great well
i i always knew i had to keep going
because it is what i do
and because it's what's in me to do and
i thank my mother
for showing me that my mother viviane
ears is a poet
so i grew up with a poet and she was not
nationally known but she was very
disciplined and committed to her work
and and in being that way she really
provided everything
we needed as young developing artists
all the classes all the exposure
and it was never about whether or not we
were going to make it
it was about
giving yourself to your work because
your work is important and
this is what you do and this is how you
honor your work by giving yourself
fully to it that's the ethic that she
taught us
so making it was i don't know if i've
made it
it's just you know it's but you never
know
you know you just don't know well
can i just say between you and sis y'all
made it
talk about it if that ain't making it i
don't know what it is
um but but it's but it talks to i mean
like great obviously you grew up
an artistic household that i'm sure was
full of music and dance and all of those
things between all of you
um and have continued obviously with
that but i'm just curious enough i know
this feels like trying to choose between
your favorite child but
is there a specific song that you just
put on and it really moves your soul
because that is a part of this too like
like music really i don't know like
giving you life blood
okay
smoking norfolk
all right all right everything
or which which particular thing he does
but
this song i'm going to run this race
okay see even thinking about it sets me
off
because the musicality of it is so
strong to begin with
what he's doing on the instrument on the
piano is
just so powerful to begin with
the lyrics of the song are piercing
and uplifting to the soul
and his voice my gosh this man's
his his vocal strength and flexibility
and the earnestness with which he
delivers his son
okay you hear me talk about you see how
i get um yeah it moves your soul
literally like i feel it coming through
there yep
yep and i guess that's the
transformative part of art and music in
general is because it can do that it can
like touch you in a way that is like
intangible but you know you can feel it
and like it's that thing when you're
doing yourself it's like what
what they're doing in the film like you
get in the zone and i'm sure there's
like a ton
of moments where you've maybe been in
the zone but is there one that you can
like think back
to and you're like yeah girl i knew i
was hitting it every mark every line i
was serving
what was your in the zone moment when
you're
when you're working you can't assess
what you're doing in that way
because if you do you're not
really doing your work but i'll tell you
this there was uh there have been a few
moments that were actually
transformative
one was in um terrell alvin mccraney's
head of passes uh
i had there was this moment where i felt
like breath and wings
literally literally lifting me up
literally and i thought that i was going
to come off the stage
and that was uh
you see how i give them a try but you
can't
always articulate these things that's
the best part
like that's why we watch it because you
don't need to articulate it because we
saw
that grace and beauty can you help me
get back
come on
this won't be a disaster that's for sure
loved hearing your voice
love that you were a part of this
because it is just such
um like a musical black experience of
life and i just love that they just
assembled all my favorite artists to
like come in here and make
it happen but the film really posits the
question of like
what you love is it a good or a bad
thing it can sometimes be something
that's destructive but when you have a
dream you have to pursue it no matter
what so i'm just curious when was that
moment for you when you knew
i'm gonna be the greatest drummer ever
or die trying
because you are you know oftentimes um
oftentimes i think people don't even
realize
that creativity is what saves their
lives
there's a story that i tell in my book
about
how i was supposed to go to juilliard
but then i also got a record deal at the
same time
and you know it was my dad's dream
for me to go to juilliard because of
course every parent wants
their son to go this conservatory that
sort of thing
and in my head i was like well wait a
minute why do you
like instead of me being the guy that
plays for this orchestra like why can i
be the guy that hires that orchestra to
do it for his own records
and um you know what's what's weird is
that uh
i'd well i joke but it's actually true
but
i kept the roots from my dad until like
our second album
so how i was able to pull that off for
the first album is kind of
amazing but um this was always my dream
you know and for me to
oftentimes we put our dreams to the side
um because we're people pleasers and
we either don't we're managing other
people's happiness and not our own
um so it was that i'll say those
first two years was hard like sneaking
out the housing where are you going uh a
friend's house and you know meanwhile
like making my record um
but i i will say that this film in 2020
especially
where all of us are in terms of finding
new creative ways to make ourselves
happy like this couldn't come at a
better better time and yes even
in the film i've learned lessons about
following my path and my own happiness
and
i'm i'm personally not the same so i'm
just very honored to be in a
a meta film that taught me the lesson as
i was teaching the lesson
so i love that and i just have to say
from your book between the prince
stories and your dad's stories they were
two of the most funniest things in that
book and i also got my look too
uh moving back to what you're talking
about with the music though because the
music in this is absolutely amazing i
feel really awkward
asking you to pick a movie of music that
moves your soul
considering that you've made so much and
i know that you're a complete audiophile
and it's probably like picking your kids
but maybe you can give us a
quick maybe top three of that song that
like in the in the
movie there yeah or or movie if you want
to do a movie even better but
i was gonna ask you what music lose your
soul but if you got a movie that moves
oh music um you know yeah
ah man that is like picking my favorite
kid i know um
i will say okay i'll say that on my okay
so one of the creative things that i did
in quarantine
um sharing music is probably like the
the thing that i did the most
quarantining between dj and make a
playlist to keep people calm
um so i actually made on my spotify
like my 100 favorite
albums of all time so
um i i will probably say that
the 1976 live album called person in
person
by the average white band um
was an album that really that
that was a transformative stage in my
life even to the point where
my first day on the tonight show
the drummer of that band steve ferroni
mailed me the exact snare drum from that
set
from that album from that soul train
episode that i saw on drum on
um if that's not paying a forward i
don't know what it is
because like that that snare drum made
my life so
um yeah for me i will say person to
person by the average white band was
like
that live album transformed my life as a
five-year-old
i love that before i leave i have to
bring into i'm gonna do a little bit of
a name drop because you have the chance
right now on disney plus to top beyonce
and lynn
to bring fire music to the disney plus
platform i'm just curious are you
texting lynn like i'm coming for you
i know y'all broke the internet but
we're about to with soul
yeah well you know even see i'm team
hamilton too so it's like
yes i i will take i will gladly take two
thirds of
of of that of that glory you know
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for first
of all let me just go ahead and say
congratulations on the film
it is truly incredible and that's saying
something considering this is pixar
and they've been wrenching laughs and
tears out of me since childhood
but i'm just curious and i want to start
with you pete about tackling this
particular story and when did y'all
decide that you wanted to
give pixar and disney their first sort
of black centered
animation and and when and how this all
sort of came about
yeah african-american part of it
sort of evolved with the process we were
talking about
souls where did we come from who are we
at the core of who we are our
personalities
and we were looking to build a story
around a person who had this
passion uh the love for something
and we after a bunch of experimentation
we hit on
jazz a jazz pianist and
that seemed like okay if this is one of
our consultants called it uh uh
uh afro uh sorry black improvisational
music
yeah and we thought okay so this main
character should be black that seems
like the right thing to do
see it would feel weird otherwise and
that's when then we reached out to a lot
of other people
to try to make sure it was authentic
that's about when kemp came on we had
the great dr genetic coal we had some
amazing
consultants from the music world inc
including like herbie hancock which
really like how did we get
to be be in the same room with herbie
hancock this is insane
so it was it was um a process of like
you know as the story evolved we we sort
of grew into it
yeah and kemp i'm going to you next
because um pete said it uh incredibly
well but it's true this film
is unbelievably like achingly authentic
i mean look the plot point in the movie
i'm not gonna spoil anything as a
brother trying to get a suit in a fade
that is like you
have to know it you have to live it so
talk about i mean sort of how you
approach that from a screenwriting
standpoint was this a minute where
you're like all right every page we got
to make sure we put a little new york we
got to put a little jazz or did you
really just try
and just make the characters as real
like but how did you do it because again
it's by design that's no accident right
i mean well
it was just important that the character
be
recognizable to me you know i'm from new
york
so and if the main character's supposed
to be my age
from the same city as me for me right
then it's like well there's certain
things that are just
fact that that have to be a part of this
guy's life
if he's actually from the same city as
me and as the same asian is the same
racism that's not saying that the
experience of all black people in new
york is the same
it's just people can tell i think in the
audience
when they're watching something if
someone like them had a part in bringing
it to the screen
i know i can tell so it was just
important that if the if black people
were five percent of the audience or
55 percent of the audience that they
just recognize
themselves and what they and what they
were seeing up there
um thankfully though the burden didn't
just fall to me i mean of course
you know you do the best that you can as
a writer but i
as i said to pete and dana early on you
get 20 black people in a room and asked
them what it means to be black
you're going to get 20 different
questions so
i really enjoyed that aspect of
collaborating with
not just consultants externally but also
internally at pixar because there's a
lot of folks who i think in their
day-to-day and their jobs
they're very good at their jobs but they
don't have an opportunity to kind of
have these
vigorous debates and discussions about
like the authenticity of certain
elements
of of a character or of a world um
but it's funny that you mentioned like
the suit and the fade because that was
one of the first
things that i brought up when you know
the plot point of him getting the suit
was there when i got there and i was
like well
he needs a haircut too they're like well
a haircut's not as important as a suit i
was like the hell it isn't
i said i couldn't get my if i couldn't
have got my barber on the phone
to get me a haircut i wouldn't have gone
to my interview at pixar
you know so like i said i had to get
lined up i had to get lined up and i was
like
trust me people will believe that if
this man is like
i'm not doing anything without my hair
done so it was a it was very funny but
of course
that's a starting point and it's fun but
then structurally it has to be sound
the great thing about pixar is this is a
house of like incredible
world storytelling and world building
and you're working with creatives like
pete and andrew stanton and lee
anchorage
and all these incredible master
storytellers so i like the challenge of
just not having like oh well we should
just put this in there because it's
black it's like no
it has to make sense from a story and
structural standpoint
and i think when you can get but when
you can walk that tightrope
the result can be transcended that's why
i'm so proud of the film that that we
came up with because
i think it's both universal while at the
same time being very specific and very
authentic
i love that look you did an incredible
job and i'm sure
everyone including myself is obviously
glad you're a part of it but in my
personal opinion you earned every inch
of your paycheck by just making sure
they got that haircut because that is
literally what i'm using as the tagline
of this movie when i tell it to people
because like that is a big question
about it is the authenticity of it
everybody always has that question
whenever they're seeing themselves
represented in a big way on screen and
there's a lot of big players that was
the way it was with
you know disney's other films like black
panther and moana and coco and luckily
we have this great rich history at pixar
and at disney of y'all doing it
incredibly well but i know a huge part
of that is making sure you get the right
lead character
so dana if you could maybe talk about
casting joe
first because jamie's jamie but this is
like
a toned-down version of jamie foxx that
i think a lot of people
i mean i don't want to say that in a bad
way but it's like you know
like he's he's almost in service to the
story but he's so much in service to
everyone around him
yeah you're right he um i mean he it
felt like a no-brainer to us
because he's an amazing dramatic actor
he's a comedian
i mean he's hilarious and he's a
musician like i actually didn't know
until we spoke with him on the the phone
the first time that he
he went to music school and i knew he i
knew he was a music
musician but i didn't know he was a
pianist and um so it just felt like
the shoe fit from day one and luckily
he was so excited about the project um
so it just worked out really well and we
feel incredibly lucky to be able to have
him as our main character
yeah i know he's he's absolutely
hilarious in it and it has to play like
the straight man and a lot of it is the
absurd things come around him and even
though he's hysterical and has his own
thing he does it
so well which i think is a mark of why
he's such an incredible actor
but when we talk about what's around him
we're really talking about this cast and
yes you guys
assembled an amazing cast of everyone
from you know adding folks like quest
love
and to be diggs but i really want to
talk about the women
that are around joe because i got to
speak with them this morning we're
talking felicia rashad
playing liva and then we have angela
bassett it's dorothea
and of course 22 with tina fey and i
want to talk with you pete
about yeah just sort of assembling the
cast to go around joe because they're
huge parts of how this movie plays
is who's gonna play off of him
yeah yeah absolutely and and you know in
a sense
joe is a bit opposed by his mom like
she's a bit of the antagonist
and so we needed somebody who could do
that in a loving way
you know she's always out for his best
interest but look this guy
has been trying for a long time to cut
it as a musician
she just wants to make sure he's going
to have food on the table so
i mean we needed somebody who could
really give him the strength of
hey move on um but also uh in a loving
way and so
you know obviously felicia rashad her
acting chops are second to none
uh it was so fun being in the room when
everybody
uh we were at backstage at d23 and uh
where we met her really for the first
time and everybody in the cast like no
matter what they were doing they stop
and everybody looks over and wants to
talk and see what's going on even
people from other movies were stopping
and coming over from star wars and stuff
so
that was fantastic and of course as you
say um uh
angela bassett brings this incredible
strength as well
to uh our the the character of our our
um
bandleader you know um she uh
is got this strength and
ability like you when she speaks i mean
even as an
uh as a director listening to her when
she says stuff you're like
oh man you know you just you totally
believe her
she's you don't mess with angela bassett
yeah um i did want to to talk about
um the new york of it because obviously
a huge part of this film is that it's
based in new york and it's obviously
very centered in on jazz where
new york you know it was born but when i
was talking to everyone
the cast who a lot of them are new york
residents went on about how
authentically
they were able to capture new york in
the
in the storyboards and in the production
design so
i'll start with you pete and then maybe
kemp if you could follow up on how
you were able to make it because it's a
it's a different look for pixar i would
say that
yeah uh thanks for noticing that's
really cool because it was one of our
explicit desires to make sure that this
film
you couldn't replace an uh you know an
image from toy story or neem or
something it's got its own look
we always are sticklers for research we
did a ton of
uh uh research we went to new york we
took tons of pictures
um the production designers were all
over like making sure that
okay if this is supposed to be midtown
what's the kind of architecture what are
the building materials what are the
things that are going to make it
recognizable but not like a photograph
because
you know there's certain things we had
to change like the the names of shops
and
specific certain buildings but you know
we're trying to
kind of grab an essence of this that
people
recognize right off the bat and that was
a lot of fun
yeah i think it was really important
that new york is five distinct boroughs
and it was important that people from
new york
recognize that like it joe where joe is
in queens
i used to live in that neighborhood so
you know it should be recognizable as
sunnyside in jackson heights and without
even someone telling you you know that
that's the 7 train
on that elevated track it was actually
funny when we released one of the first
trip i think it was one of the first
trailers right pete
tina fey actually messaged us she was
like when the 7 train went behind silver
cup studios
she was like you know it brought back
memories of all the years i worked on
recording 30 rock
in those studios so that's what i mean
it was like there's certain iconic shots
of new york that you think of
like the statue of liberty and the
empire state building but it was so
great to get those iconic shots
that are only iconic to a commuter from
queens
you know like it is they're iconic to us
to someone coming from brooklyn or
queens or the bronx we have our own
iconography
of of the city and and it's it's in the
roads it's in the shops it's in things
like that
um i just the sequence when we go into
the subway
is one of my favorite in in the whole
film because i was like man it's almost
like
you can smell that subway station and
when they go down there
so it's yeah they really did a great job
it's so funny you mentioned that because
that's actually one of my favorite
scenes in the movie is the whole subway
section as a non-new york resident but
as someone that goes there very often
for work
the subway is really the most common
thing about new york for me it's
kind of how i got around and it is both
the blessing and the curse that it is in
the movie of the like
yeah you're gonna get to see some of the
best musicians in the world
literally playing um in the stop but
then you're also gonna wonder what is
left on the seat and why is it wet
why is that person talking to themselves
you know there's all of that
and again it it sort of centers in on
the authenticity of
what you guys were able to sort of
create with this cast but
looking at it from i guess a a wider
scale going back to the look of it even
to the character designs
because i don't know the name of this i
apologize it was an art history major
but there's these old pictures of black
jazz musicians and like trumpets and
they're elongated and they have that and
i
felt that in this and so dana i have to
ask you was that like
part of it from like the first draft
that you guys were maybe
you know doing a little crib sheet on
those and tell me i'm wrong you can
we looked at a lot of old photographs to
be honest um our art department
i mean it's amazing what they present
before they even get to the actual
drawing of characters it's like they go
through
all kinds of reviews with pete and kemp
of just kind of like
what that look is gonna be and um we did
really want
um a stylized look and pushed look for
these characters
so you definitely picked up on it for
sure
i love it i love it yeah again it's a
different pixar film but it still has
all of the heart to it but it's also a
different pixar film which we'll
probably see some more in the future
you guys had to finish this while in
quarantine correct like you were still
in post-production when we sort of shut
down and although i'm so glad that
audiences are going to get to see the
film
this year it is the christmas gift that
we need in 2020. i can think everyone
will agree to that when they see it
um what was it like having to finish a
movie in
quarantine dana and what were some of
the challenges y'all had to kind of
overcome
we had seven weeks left of production
left when we went into shelter and place
here at pixar
or in the bay area um and so honestly i
think
pete kemp and i looked at each other and
like see in a few weeks a month i don't
like we didn't we were so naive
clearly we're like oh this coronavirus
things we'll see in a bit
but we really didn't know what was going
to happen if we were going to finish on
time but
it was it was miraculous everyone picked
up their machines
took them home and started working
within a couple days they were
being productive and um i think
uh the hardest part is that our crew a
lot of people haven't even seen the film
um we haven't seen each other uh but we
did finish on time and we
did the mix up at skywalker and distance
mass
ways and pretty crazy but um
yeah we have amazing people working on
the film that finished it
so that's not loveable
i mean it's yeah it's incredible to
think that you guys finished that i'm
always like as we
are you know i learned how to do zoom in
the quarantine really well we all had to
develop new skill sets um as we were at
home but
in the end the movie is still the same
it still has that heart it still has
the funniness it still is entertaining
for both kids and parents which i think
is
again the reason why it should get out
there as quickly as possible
um bringing it back to sort of the other
huge part of the movie which is the
music and you guys really did
assemble an all-star team to bring not
just
the music that joe is playing but the
music that surrounds him in the film
so kemp and maybe pete if you guys can
talk about the musicians that you all
employed outside of the ones that you
put on
on the in the cast you guys put some
other ones behind the scenes
yeah i mean the music is really one of
the highlights of this film
for for me i mean john batiste i'm gonna
let pete get into john bautista a little
bit more because
he had a he had an impact i think on our
whole our whole crew
i i mean if you i can't speak positively
enough about just like his energy as a
human being
just like in his he he should be like
the global ambassador for jazz music
because
i just he he's a student of the music
he's a he's a polymath he can he can
demonstrate different jazz musicians
through history their style like you
just
you say a name and he can play their
music on the piano
um and i think that i hope that this
film
demonstrates to audiences a whole like a
lot more of what john bautista
is capable of but we really couldn't
have had a better and don't forget
joe's hands in the film are actually
modeled after john batiste
so we jokingly say internally that jamie
foxx is joe's head
and john bautista is on joe's hands so
our animations
use lots of photos john batiste has long
gangly fingers and he hits the keys
really hard
to the point that his pianos often have
to be re-tuned very often
yes when you see the animation of that
playing
it's just all like john john batiste
flair um
and then the score i mean i was a huge
fan of trent rezner and atticus ross
as nine inch nails and of course of
their work and scores
so i remember when pete first brought it
up like it almost seemed like it was a
joke he was like
what do you think about trent rezner and
atticus ross and i was like for what
he's like for the score i was like what
that'd be awesome
just because it's so it seems so crazy
at the time
and that was what excited us because we
were so he was so about like
doing new things i think a lot of people
don't know that about pete doctor
is that there have been sequels to his
movies but pete doesn't do sequels
is when he finishes a film it's funny
i'll bring up something and he's like oh
well i don't want to talk about that
anymore because
i did it and i've moved on to the next
thing so pete's favorite movie
is always the movie he's currently
working on even before it's done
and i love that because he wants to do
things completely different than the
last thing he did and i think with this
with this film
it was like p unchained because it was
like the score it was like a whole new
set of collaborators of which i was just
one
but i think there was a whole new set of
collaborators all up and down the chain
and the trent reznor and atticus ross i
mean
i i love the score to this movie i i
mean talk about
i think it was kind of a stroke of
genius to integrate them into this
we also got to hear cody chestnut came
into play of course he's on the subway
that you're talking about
and you know the amazing cleverers that
that john brought in including like the
great roy haynes
and you know just brilliant players
i love it and again um as the music sort
of like
flows through it it really does sort of
like sweep you up and allow you to stay
immersed in it obviously that's a huge
part of any great animation is is having
an incredible score behind it
um i feel bad asking this pete since you
don't want to go back in time but
inside out soul snl ladies
talking about our inner emotions and
where we are i'm seeing some patterns
here
so i'm just curious is there a little
like you know put a little amy and tina
together like get him some like rivalry
like if you get a best picture
nomination for seoul it like tops inside
out just a little bit because they only
got a screenwriter
yeah no i think you know obviously i
love working with
smart people and both of them are just
tops you know
we we not only uh tina great performer
but uh helped out a little bit with the
writing too you know she came in and
did some punch up and and uh man just uh
what a pleasure to be able to work with
people like that you know
you